Tim Ferriss: Good afternoon, this is Edward
Murrow.
Ladies and gentlemen.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of The Tim Ferriss
Show, ladies and gentlemen.
I have one of my favorite people in front
of me, Kevin Kelly.
Who's Kevin Kelly?
Kevin Kelly helped launch and edit Wired magazine.
He has written for The New York Times, and
The Wall Street Journal, among many other
publications.
He's the author of the new book Excellent
Advice for Living: Wisdom I Wish I'd Known
Earlier.
I have a lot to say about this book.
We will get into it.
Other books by Kevin Kelly include Out of
Control, the 1994 classic book on decentralized
emergent systems; The Silver Cord, a graphic
novel about robots and angels; What Technology
Wants, a robust theory of technology; Vanishing
Asia, his 50-year project to photograph the
disappearing cultures of Asia, and The Inevitable:
Understanding the 12 Technological Forces
That Will Shape Our Future, a New York Times
bestseller.
Kevin is currently co-chair of The Long Now
Foundation, which is building a clock in a
mountain that will tick for 10,000 years,
of course.
He also has a daily blog, a weekly podcast
about cool tools and a weekly newsletter,
Recomendo, a free, one-page list of six very
brief recommendations of cool stuff.
You can find that at recomendo.com.
That is R-E-C-O-M-E-N-D-O.com.
I was going to say R-E-C-O-M-E-N-DO.com.
You get the idea.
So recomendo.com.
Take a look.
He is also a senior maverick at Wired and
lives in Pacifica, California.
You can find him on Twitter @Kevin2Kelly,
Kevin, the number two, Kelly, and all things
Kevin at kk.org.
Kevin, nice to see you again.
Kevin Kelly: Tim, it's always a pleasure and
just seeing you makes me happy.
Tim Ferriss: Likewise.
Kevin Kelly: So glad to be here.
Tim Ferriss: Hey, I saw you walk in.
I was chatting with Harley of Shopify earlier
today, and you walked in, and I saw you across
the room with your yellow baseball cap on.
Doesn't hide the beard, though.
So, I spotted you and also just made me very
happy to see you.
I was thinking about that and how incredibly
valuable that is.
What a gift.
Kevin Kelly: It is.
And I'm glad to be seen.
And so I'm so glad to be able to share with
you another time of exploring some ideas and
just see where they go.
Tim Ferriss: Now, ideas, you're a man of ideas,
and I thought for comic relief, we might start
with a list of possible topics to discuss
with Kevin Kelly.
So, I just want to read these, because people
who are perhaps not long-term listeners may
not have heard our previous conversations.
And I believe the title I used, you did not
choose this, I chose it, for our first conversation,
was "Kevin Kelly, the Real-Life Most Interesting
Man in the World."
Something along those lines.
People may say, "What hyperbole.
What is this nonsense?"
But wait, allow me to list the possible topics,
and I ask every guest to send possible bullets
for exploration.
So, here we go.
And then I will return to a few of these.
"The most popular thing I've ever written:
1,000 True Fans." "2008: why we built a clock
that will tick for 10,000 years inside a mountain."
"I've had a daily blog for 20 years, for five
years a weekly podcast."
"At Wired, we invented the click-on advertising
banner for the web.
Next, I spent 11 years creating a huge graphic
novel about angels and robots, released on
Kickstarter, The Silver Cord."
We're going to come back to that.
"My failed campaign to discover all the species
of life on Earth."
"In 2003, I made a long bet on the collapse
of the global human population by 2060."
"My TED Talk on why we should be optimistic
in 10 minutes."
"The most important article I've ever written."
"My case against belief in an AI singularity."
"My most recent piece in Wired extolling the
glories of generative AI engines of wow."
"I co-founded The Hackers Conference in 1984,
still going."
"My 50-year passion project," and this goes
on, "weighing 30 pounds," about Vanishing
Asia.
"I rode my bike across America twice, once
west to east, once north to south."
"I make a piece of art every day."
"My biggest audience, and most of my fans
are in China, where I'm known simply as KK."
"I have a screen credit for working with Spielberg
on the sci-fi concepts for Minority Report."
"With a friend, I built a two-family house
from scratch, cutting down the trees."
It goes on and on and on, right?
"The story of my religious conversion on This
American Life in 1997."
"I made a music video in 1969, 12 years before
MTV."
Lest people think I'm exaggerating —
Kevin Kelly: It sounds ridiculous now that
you mention it.
Tim Ferriss: It does sound ridiculous, and
thank God I'm a specialist in the ridiculous.
So I thought we would start with this bet.
"In 2003, I made a long bet on the collapse
of the global human population by 2060."
What is a long bet and which direction did
you bet?
Were you betting on or against?
Kevin Kelly: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: And why?
Kevin Kelly: So Long Bets is a service that
we set up at the Long Now Foundation, which
I can explain a little bit more about that,
which is meant to encourage long-term thinking.
So we made a place where we could have a long
bet, meaning more than two years, about some
socially significant wager.
And the idea would be that there would be
a public bet and you'd be accountable for
it, and there'd be money involved in the wager.
And the idea was to also require people to
put the logic of why they were going in a
certain direction.
And that, over time, if you had enough of
this, you could see which kinds of logic and
what kinds of thinking would win more often.
And to get around the laws of betting at the
time, which basically is illegal to make a
bet, that's been kind of slowly changing.
But we engineered a kind of a hacker, which
you could make a donation to.
Well, you would use the money and the money
would go to the foundation, the nonprofit
of the person who won the bet.
So my bet, and by the way, there are a lot
of people who bet on, including Warren Buffett,
made a million-dollar bet that basically index
funds would beat any investment hedge fund.
He won.
Well, again, his charity won.
My bet about the population was that the population
of the world, the global population of the
world, by 2060, I think it was —
Tim Ferriss: 2060.
Kevin Kelly: — would be the same as it was
at the time of the bet, which is, I think,
2003.
So the idea is that we are coming up to a
peak of human population that would then on
the other side go down.
So you very commonly see the chart of the
rising population.
But it's interesting to me that you never
see what happens on the other side.
And what happens on the other side as far
as we can tell, is that it plummets.
And that's because —
Tim Ferriss: Resource scarcity?
Kevin Kelly: No.
Tim Ferriss: Education and falling birth rates?
Kevin Kelly: Just falling birth rates because
modern people, on average, are not having
more than two kids per couple.
And this is common.
So fertility is falling all around the planet,
including right now, even in the US.
And everything that we've tried, we being
humans, have tried collectively to counter
that, has not worked.
So Japan is famously losing the total number
of people, not just having a lower birth rate.
They actually have a decline in population,
but they're actually not the lowest birth
rate, which is South Korea.
And China is aging, Mexico is aging faster
than the US.
So all the people that have been coming from
Mexico, Mexico will want to have come back
at some point.
So it's a really significant change.
And again, it's possible that we could use
technology to change it, maybe have artificial
wombs or who knows what.
But right now, for the average person, they're
not inclined to have a lot of children.
And the people who do have children don't
have enough to cover for those who don't,
in terms of the world population.
You can have immigration, which is what the
US has been doing all along, basically stealing
people from other countries.
But that doesn't help you globally.
So here's where it's the problem.
For a lot of environmentalists, this is good
news because there's less people who are —
Tim Ferriss: Consuming.
Kevin Kelly: Consuming resources.
But throughout history, we've always only
had rising living standards with rising population.
Tim Ferriss: Really?
Kevin Kelly: Yes.
We have no experience —
Tim Ferriss: Do you think those are causal
or correlated?
Kevin Kelly: That's the question.
I think there's obviously some feedback loop
where the more people you have, the more ideas
you have, the more wealth you have, and that
allows you to have more kids.
But we don't know.
So, all we can say is we have no experience
in having living standards with a smaller
population, a smaller audience, smaller market
every year.
Tim Ferriss: What do you think are the implications
of this?
And is 2060 just after the apex?
Will it have been declining for a period of
time?
When is the projected apex, if you have a
projection?
Kevin Kelly: Right.
So that's one of the evidences is that this
peak is keeps moving closer.
Okay.
Because —
Tim Ferriss: Right.
It's not static.
Kevin Kelly: Well, it's not static, but it
also means that there's all the projections
about the increase in population that people
are assuming and built into some of these
demographic models are being revised all the
time.
So that peak keeps moving closer.
And the height of the peak, the numbers of
actually how high it is, is changing.
I think one of the things that's really important
to understand for us in our society right
now is that if you ask any question at the
global level, the answer is, "We have no idea."
And the one thing we know most about is human
population.
And I think our number or counting of that
is probably off by 10 percent, plus or minus.
And that's the thing that we know the most
about globally.
But if you ask how much fresh water is there?
How much electricity is being generated?
Globally, the answer is is that we really
don't know.
We have a very poor view of us globally, partly
because there's areas of the world that are
so undeveloped, we don't have very good countings
—
Tim Ferriss: I see poor view meaning we just
have very incomplete understanding.
Kevin Kelly: Yes.
We don't have a global census, we don't have
a global way of viewing.
We have now satellites that can help us see,
but they can't count everything.
And so I think what we're doing as a species
is moving into this era where we'll become
a global.
We have a global economy, we have a global
view, a global machine.
All the internets connected together and we'll
act more globally and maybe increasingly some
global governance, but we're not there yet.
And so even something as primal and essential,
as foundational, as our population, I think
we don't even, don't know.
Tim Ferriss: Have you had any exposure to
or interaction with the Santa Fe Institute?
I have not.
But I've recently had conversations with a
number of people, Bill Gurley and others who
are involved, complex adaptive systems.
And I'd just be curious to know what your
exposure has been, what your opinion is.
Kevin Kelly: So my first book was written
about basically the Santa Fe Institute.
Out Of Control was based from a conference
that was initiated by a conference I went
to at Los Alamos, and Santa Fe was hosting
one of the first conferences.
I would go down there and talk to all the
scientists.
And this is in the late '80s.
And that was the beginning of the sort of
complex adaptive system view of the world.
And so that's what Out Of Control is about,
is looking at that view and saying the way
biology works and the way this complex technology
works are very similar.
They have very similar dynamics because they're
complex adaptive systems.
What we want to make with the internet, with
all its penetrations, that you can think of
spam as an invading virus that you have to
— you can't eliminate, but you have to treat
it like an immune system where you keep it
at bay.
And so adopting some of these biological dynamics
and applying it to machines and a lot of the
work in trying to make robots and early AI,
again, we're modeling off of what was being
learned and often reported or sponsored by
the Santa Fe Institute and that kind of approach
to complex adaptive systems.
So, yes, I think it's incredibly important.
And for me, it was a transformative framing
of the complicated things was to think of
them in these terms.
My whole book was about the fact that the
world of the made and the world of the born
are basically the same, two faces of the same
kind of dynamic.
And so you could look at how meadows work
in ecosystems, and then you could look at
the internet, which was just beginning, and
now of course, it's in full bloom.
And you can see how social media, they have
similar behaviors.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
And you can find thing in one that you then
find in the other in surprising ways, sort
of life imitating art and art imitating life,
in the sense that we think we have invented
gears.
And then we are like, "Oh, wait a second.
Actually, there are insects that use gears
for types of jumping."
How wild is that?
Kevin Kelly: Right.
So, there's biomimicry, that was the field,
which was kind of using those as models for
ideas and frameworks for trying to make mechanical
things.
And that only takes you so far.
I mean that was the, maybe the genius or the
breakthrough in the Wright Brothers, which
is like, we didn't make flying machines by
flapping —
Tim Ferriss: Strapping wings to people.
Kevin Kelly: But by flapping our wings, it
was like you put a big surfboard on it and
you fly.
So, there's limits to it, and right now with
the AI stuff, there's lots of looking at the
neurology and of course we call them neuronets.
So there is huge amount of influence.
But what I'm saying is even maybe a little
stronger, which is that it isn't as if these
mechanical systems are imitating biology.
I'm saying they actually have the same dynamics.
The dynamics that are powering biology are
powering the technium and the technology.
It's the same.
Tim Ferriss: I think we are quite close on
that in the sense that both paths end up in
the same places.
And I would tend to agree.
Los Alamos, is there any particular reason
they chose Los Alamos?
Kevin Kelly: So, Los Alamos, there were a
lot of physicists left over from the Manhattan
Project who liked living there.
And Murray Gell-Mann was the prime mover.
And so he liked it.
And I think he might have been instrumental
in finding the funding for it, and he was
on the chair for a very long time.
And they had spaces to convene and people,
so Santa Fe was close to Los Alamos, and that
was the reason why it was in Santa Fe.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
I've been revisiting some of Richard Feynman's
writing.
Kevin Kelly: And he might have been part of
that whole thing too.
I mean he loved —
Tim Ferriss: He was there, for sure.
Kevin Kelly: I mean, in terms of [inaudible]
Santa Fe.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I see, that group.
That I don't know.
But certainly that is part of the reason I
asked about Los Alamos.
It's on the brain.
So let's take a hard left, which is I think
going to be common in this conversation.
And we will probably come back, we'll almost
certainly come back to AI, but I don't want
to open that can of worms just yet.
Kevin Kelly: Right, right.
Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
You spent 11 years creating a huge graphic
novel about angels and robots.
Silver Cord.
I am, you may or may not know this, but deeply
interested in comic books and collected for
a very long time, spent all of my allowance,
all of my work money, almost all of it, on
comics for a very long period of time, wanted
to be a penciller.
Why did it take 11 years?
And what did the process of translating your
thinking and writing to that form look like?
What were the steps?
Kevin Kelly: I met a friend who actually was
actually comic book artist, had published,
and wanted to do another one.
And I'd kind of always wanted to try my hand
at it because I thought that this was a brilliant
genre for communicating lots of things.
And particularly if you're interested in science
fiction, it was sort of like to me a little
better than a novel because it had that kind
of immersive visualization, which I love.
I'm a very visual person, but it wasn't so
detailed that you needed to make a movie of
it.
But we thought we could do both.
And we thought that maybe we could write something
that would have some appeal, be making movies.
So we would try to write it, the script, as
if we were writing a movie.
And so some of the other associates that we
had, worked for Pixar, some story later.
Tim Ferriss: You say associates, it sounds
like a law firm.
What do you mean?
Kevin Kelly: Well, I mean —
Tim Ferriss: Collaborators.
Friends.
Kevin Kelly: Actually, here's what it was.
My friend and these other friends all went
to the same church.
So we were all in the same church, and there
were people who worked at Pixar and some people
who worked at ILM.
And so I had this idea of doing this book
or this story, and the story was, the premise
of it was I was imagining that there would
be these interdimensional beings.
We're calling them angels.
They're made out of light because they're
intangible, and that they would look down
on humans and weep when they saw us because
we were getting the ride that they craved,
that embodiment, and we were squandering it.
So that's the basic premise, is that there
is this realm and there's these beings and
they're waiting their turn to be embodied,
and they're looking at us and what we're doing
with — it's like, "You have the ultimate…"
Tim Ferriss: You're blowing it, guys.
Kevin Kelly: And you're blowing it.
It's like, what would I do?
I would smother my face with mango juice and
I would take a dive into the ocean and swim
underwater, the whole — so that was the
premise of it.
And then the added part of it was that some
of these angelic beings would try to cheat
by becoming embodied into robots.
They wouldn't go through the traditional preparation
that you require of moral guidance and whoever
else you needed to be before you were allowed
to be in a human.
But they were going to cheat by coming into
robots.
Tim Ferriss: Skipping a few steps.
Kevin Kelly: Skipping a few steps, and these
would be kind of unhinged or rogue because
they weren't.
So, anyway, that's the premise.
So you had these angels and robots and it
was a graphic novel, and we would tell stories.
And the issue was I'd never written fiction
in my life, although the Pixar people had.
They were from the story side, and I couldn't
draw to the level necessary.
So, we worked on it.
And the reason why it took 11 years was we
made it way too big.
Instead of doing it like little 20-page things.
Tim Ferriss: Decided to do —
Kevin Kelly: Decided the whole thing.
300.
Tim Ferriss: Lord of the Rings in one go.
Kevin Kelly: Exactly.
No, actually, we got a advance from Simon
& Schuster to do it, and we were late in delivering,
and the guy who bought it left.
They wanted it back, blah, blah, blah.
Tim Ferriss: Occupational hazard in publishing.
Kevin Kelly: Exactly right.
So it took us that long just to finish, and
we actually Kickstarted it to print it.
Tim Ferriss: When you were generating the
story, were you doing it in effectively screenplay
form?
Kevin Kelly: Yes.
It was written as a screenplay script.
Tim Ferriss: And what did you hope?
What did you collectively, and maybe it was
different person-to-person, hope this story
would do, if anything?
Kevin Kelly: It's a really good question,
and that's the most important question you
always want to be asking yourself when you're
doing these.
What effect do you want to have on people?
How do you want them to feel after they're
done?
Do you want them to change their behavior?
And for me, it was this idea of the genesis
of it, which was to nudge people a little
bit more, to take advantage of this special
time that we have to interact with each other.
This is what you get by being embodied, is
that there's far more influence.
We can influence things through the physical
way that we can't when we're intangible beings.
And that was the issue that these other dimensional
beings had, is that they don't have as much
influence.
It's really hard for them to influence because
having a body means that you can influence
things by interacting with them physically.
And that's very powerful.
Tim Ferriss: And experience things.
Kevin Kelly: And experience things, right.
And so that's what it was.
It was an ode or a nudge for people to maybe
appreciate their own lives, meaning literally
their life, much more than they do.
Tim Ferriss: I dig it, Kevin Kelly.
You're good at helping friends, myself included,
to do that IRL, in real life too, through
experiences, and we may come back to that,
but first, the iconic “1,000 True Fans.”
The most popular thing you've ever written.
Why do you think that is the case, and what
would you double-down on or revise if you
were to take another stab at it today?
Kevin Kelly: So, the honest answer, one of
the reasons why it's very — we can talk
about maybe why it's good and useful and then
why it's popular.
The reason why it's popular is actually through
you.
The fact that you included it in one of your
books, and that's sort of lifted it out of
my little realm.
The reason why maybe it kind of resonates
with people is because there is sort of an
assumption that the goal is to hit it big,
the big-time bestseller, a hit.
And most people kind of come to associate
those numbers, that kind of large scale, with
success.
And the idea that success could look differently,
that you could have a more modest-size scale
and that be successful, sometimes is dismissed
as lifestyle businesses or whatever.
And I kind of realized that technology would
allow a different version of that.
You could have it, that it was possible and
that it would be good.
It would be good for people.
And so that was, I think, people can resonate
with that because it's a viable alternative
option to things that was not spoken before.
It was not even really on the radar.
And when I wrote it, when I first wrote it,
before you even saw it, there was no Kickstarter,
there was no Patreon.
And I was challenged with people like Jaron
Lanier to say, "Well, that's a nice theory,
but there isn't any evidence that this is
actually working."
It was actually at that time, I did a follow
through and I tried to find evidence, and
there was evidence of established artists
from publishing, or music, or studios who
had already an audience and could move off
of that to their own, But there wasn't any
evidence of an indigenous organic growth from
nothing.
Now there is.
Every day people write to me, and meet me,
and say, "Yes, I have been able to do that,"
inspired someone by hearing of that possibility.
Tim Ferriss: Is there anything that you would
modify in that piece, or emphasize more?
Kevin Kelly: I did a modification for you
where I talked about the fact that, again,
one benefit and one disadvantage.
The one benefit is that part of what we're
doing is, if all you need is 1,000 true fans,
then even if your interests are one in a million,
given the population of the Earth of billions
of people, that means that there's 1,000 people
who potentially, on the planet, who will share
your interests.
So if your interests are only one in a million
people can identify with, that you still have
enough.
Then, the second thing was that, just to emphasize
to people, this is not for everybody, that
tending the fans and interacting with them
is almost like a halftime job, at least, maybe
even more.
Not everybody's suited to do that.
An artist might just want to paint, they don't
want to deal with fans.
We see more of dealing with fans, what it
means, is it's not always pretty, and it can
burn you out.
So I just want to emphasize that this is an
option.
Secondly, you don't have to go all the way.
You can have your thousand true fans and then
you can have lots of other casual fans and
other fans which would allow you to have other
people help you.
So it's not just you.
Then, secondly, for some people you want to
have intermediaries.
It's just not something you want to spend
your time doing and that's perfectly fine,
but it's a really great place to be able to
start from.
Maybe you don't want to land there, but that's
one of my pieces of advice, is that where
you start is not where you're going to land,
and so this is a good place to start.
Tim Ferriss: That's exactly what I was going
to say, which is even if you want to hypothetically
build a huge company and change the world,
although I'm very skeptical of people who
lead with that, I think most businesses fundamentally
are lifestyle businesses.
If you really double-click and look at it
closely enough, even if someone aims to be
a Fortune 500 CEO.
In any case, the point I want to make is even
if you have these very lofty large scale goals,
beginning with the exercise of reading “1,000
True Fans,” and at least considering what
your approach would be to accomplish that
first, is a great fundamental step.
Kevin Kelly: Right?
And, partly, that is because you get 1,000
true fans by accumulating them one by one,
and if you are focused on today I'm going
to get one more additional customer, that
is tremendously powerful.
Customer by customer, are they happy, am I
giving value to them?
If you can focus on that, that is incredibly
a superpower.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, for sure, and if you can
take those 1,000 true fans and some subset
of them become your PR slash marketing forces,
then things can multiply very quickly.
I promised left turns, we're going to take
another left turn.
Your failed campaign to discover all the species
of life on Earth.
So we went, I wanted to hit a highlight, and
maybe this is also a highlight, but I would
love for you to expand on this.
Lessons learned.
What happened?
Kevin Kelly: So there was conversation I was
part of, and I was sitting next to a billionaire
who said, "It's actually hard to give away
a billion dollars," and for some reason I
thought at that moment, well, actually I know
what I would do, and that would be I would
hire all the local indigenous people and have
them be barefoot taxonomists and go out and
discover, and catalog count all the living
species on this planet because we've never
done that, and by the way, if we found life
on another planet, that's the first thing
we would do is a systematic survey of all
the life on that planet, but we haven't done
that on our own home planet, and because you're
paying locals, it would distribute that money
down really, really fast.
Stewart Brand was sitting next to me and he
thought it was a cool idea, and then I didn't
think anything more of it because I have ideas,
I have a lot of ideas, I'm giving it away,
and then a week later, Stewart said, "Let's
do that idea," and I said, "What idea?"
I'd forgotten about it already.
He said, "You know, the idea at dinner about
accounting all the species," and I said, "Yeah,
I don't know.
It's like we're not taxonomists.
I'm not a biologist," and Stewart's hunch
was that, with new technology, and this is
my bias too, we might be able to do that in
addition to it.
Tim Ferriss: Could you just briefly explain
for people who don't know who Stewart Brand
is?
Kevin Kelly: So Stewart Brand is a close friend
and the person who first hired me.
He invented The Whole Earth Catalog in 1969,
and the best way to describe The Whole Earth
Catalog is it was kind of like your information
guide to the world before there was the internet.
Steve Jobs famously called it "the internet
before there was an internet."
It was internet printed on newsprint because
it was reader generated.
So before YouTube, before anything, if you
wanted to find out how to build a house, or
repair your VW bug, or start a homeschool,
or keep bees, where would you go?
There was literally no place to find that
information.
Libraries didn't have that information.
There was no internet to look it up, but The
Whole Earth Catalog started to accumulate
those, and there was, readers of it would
send in their versions like, oh, the best
book on gold panning is this thing, and then
Stewart would run it, print it, and run it,
right away.
And there was no advertising.
It was kind of reader supported.
So that was Stewart Brand.
He went on to do things.
We started The Well together, which was the
first online access to the internet and other
things.
So, he's my hero, and he just had a recent
book, a biography written about him by John
Markoff, The New York Times' tech writer,
and Markoff's theory is — and so anyway,
Stewart has been sort of at the center or
at the leading edge of almost, first the beatniks,
and then the hippies, and then the digital
thing —
Tim Ferriss: He's like the Forrest Gump of
25 seminal moments in history.
Kevin Kelly: Right.
He's kind of always there.
His background was biology.
He was a biologist for a study with Paul Ehrlich,
who was The Population Bomb guy on the other
side of this argument about population.
So, Stewart was sitting there, Stewart started
along now with me, and Danny Hillis, and Peter
Schwartz to think about, to encourage long-term
thinking, to be a good ancestor.
How do we be good ancestors?
And, at that dinner, Stewart said, later on,
he said, we should really try and do this.
It would be kind of a great thing.
So, we actually started a foundation called
All Species.
I named it All Species Inventory, All Species
Foundation, and we were going to try and raise
money, not from the usual sources that funded
taxonomy.
We didn't want to take any money from there
because it was really pitiful, the amount
of money, but to find it from the Silicon
Valley and get money for developing the technology
that would be able to do that, and it was
just too early.
It was just too early.
Tim Ferriss: Too early in what respects?
Kevin Kelly: Well, right now, on my phone,
I have Merlin, which will identify a bird
song.
I have [Seek], which will identify almost
any plant or mushroom.
That's what we needed.
Tim Ferriss: I see, technologically speaking.
Kevin Kelly: Yes, and you needed it because
even those aren't going to identify a new
one, if you have an app that can identify
the known ones, then you're only going to
bother the taxonomists with one that isn't
identified, so right now, otherwise, people
are just sending the about, oh, this is a
—
Tim Ferriss: Too much replication.
Kevin Kelly: — brand new species and they're
saying, no, this is not a new one, don't bother
me with that one.
So that's what we needed, and we were just
25 years too early in terms of technology
being available to be able to assist this,
and so it became kind of a catalog of existing
species, and that was the thing that shocked
us, was, okay, well first we need is a list
of all the existing species.
This is whatever this is, 2008 or something.
There isn't one.
It was like, what?
Well, there's all these taxonomic publications
that they're all buried in these obscure publications
that haven't been digitized yet.
It was like, so I was like, oh, my gosh, this
is even further behind than we thought, so
that is sort of what it became.
It became kind of a program just to digitize
the existing known species, and then the other
thing is that, as they started to do that,
they realized that there was this huge duplication
of species having more than one name because
there being, you know, somebody in Germany
and somebody in Japan, and not even knowing
that they're talking about the same thing.
So it was failed in the sense that we still
don't know all the species on this planet.
We don't even know how many we don't know,
and we're still only beginning to have a central,
integrated, comprehensive, complete catalog
of what we do know, and it's called the Encyclopedia
of Life, and E.O.
Wilson, before he died, was involved in that,
Tim Ferriss: The legendary E.O.
Wilson.
Kevin Kelly: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Mr. Consilience.
Kevin Kelly: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Stewart Brand.
Let's spend a little more time on Stewart
Brand.
Kevin Kelly: Who has been a guest on your
show.
Tim Ferriss: He has been a guest.
He's spectacular.
He is, what would you say his age is now?
Kevin Kelly: He's 86, maybe.
Tim Ferriss: Something like that, and I interviewed
him not that long ago, and he was doing CrossFit
two or three times a week.
Kevin Kelly: Yes, right.
Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Also, military background, you
just have to read his bio to even begin to
try to believe it.
He would be, also, maybe on your short list
for real-world most interesting men in the
world.
Kevin Kelly: Yes, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Now, I recall chatting with Stewart,
I believe, about resurrection of species.
So the potential of Jurassic Park style, resurrecting,
say, woolly mammoths and reintroducing some
of these large, terrestrial, herbivores for
any host of reasons.
What do you think the future holds for those
types of plans?
Kevin Kelly: Yeah, so Stewart, Ryan Phelan,
and I, who did All Species, and Stewart and
Ryan went on to do the Revive and Restore
is the name of their program, and it is to
originally, the totem animal was the mammoth,
the woolly mammoth, was to bring that back,
and there are a lot of very interesting reasons
why to do that, and the way that they do,
is basically to take existing Asian elephants
and winterizing them through breeding.
Tim Ferriss: I got it.
Kevin Kelly: Accelerated breeding.
So you're not just going to hatch out of a
test tube, a brand new woolly mammoth.
There would be a sense in which you would
kind of reuse the line of existing elephants
to try and reverse engineer that.
Tim Ferriss: You take a Mendelian approach
to —
Kevin Kelly: But that's a little bit longer
term, and actually, Stewart and I went to,
and George Church, went to Siberia to go get
samples of the mammoths that were being exposed
by the thawing permafrost.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Kevin Kelly: So to get the DNA from the right,
through the trunk —
Tim Ferriss: Jurassic Park Seven, scene one.
Kevin Kelly: Right, right.
Tim Ferriss: Opening.
Kevin Kelly: Exactly, so that was quite an
experience, but there are other animals that
are closer to being able to, they're going
to be a little bit easier to do it.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
All right, well, optimism.
You're one of the most optimistic people I
know, I think, that is a great influence on
me and the world, and I sometimes push back
on some of it.
Kevin Kelly: Of course.
You should.
Tim Ferriss: So what would be your, doesn't
have to be an elevator pitch, could just be
a very long elevator ride because we have
infinite time —
Kevin Kelly: 30 floors.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, exactly.
That's right.
Moving as slowly as you would like — what
is the argument for why we should be optimistic?
Kevin Kelly: Generally, people see optimism
as kind of a temperament, it's a sunny view,
and I think there is some of that, and I have
a natural amount of it, but over time, I've
actually become even more optimistic than
my general tendency, deliberately.
It's kind of like a learned optimism, and
I think the reason we should be as optimistic
as we can is because it is how we make really
good things, good, complicated things.
It's hard enough.
Well, I mean, it's very hard to make good
complicated things work because generally
there's more way things can fail than they
can succeed, and it's very unlikely that we're
going to make something really good that's
complicated, inadvertently.
They're hard to do.
So we have to see it and believe that it can
be done, and that is where the optimism comes
in, is envisioning something and then believing
that you could make it real.
Because, when we look back on history, and
that's where a lot of my optimism comes, we
realize that most of the things that we have
now have been made by people who are optimistic.
Reviewing that it was possible to make them,
and believe that they were going to make them,
and could imagine them.
So, I think of it as a work of imagination
where you kind of imagine a good scenario,
which is harder to do than imagining a scenario
where it fails or collapses.
It is much easier to imagine how things break
than it is to see how they work, and that's
why entrepreneurs and all the others are rightly
lauded because they're going against that
grain.
It is hard to imagine how we could have this
thing that seems like it is improbable, and
most things that work are improbable.
That's the definition from the Santa Fe complexity
theory, is that things breaking down is the
probable.
Complicated things working are improbable
by definition.
And, so you're against the improbable.
And that work of imagining the improbable
and having the improbable succeed, and believing
it can, is optimism, which means that the
optimists are the ones who shape our future.
So I'd like to give a little story of a car,
and you need to have brakes on the car to
steer the car —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'm with you so far.
Kevin Kelly: — but the engine is actually
the more important element, and so there are
people and there are organizations, and there
are methods that are going to be doing the
braking, and I think they're essential.
I want brakes in the car, but I just feel
that the brake can overwhelm and cause stagnation,
and that we also wanted to remember to focus
on making the engine even stronger, and so
I emphasized the engine.
Tim Ferriss: So I want to take a closer look
at the engine.
So if things breaking down are the probable,
and there are many more ways things can go
wrong than they can go, if I'm hearing you
correctly, and maybe also bringing in some
of my own position, it would be that you can
have, that active optimism is probably more
valuable than passive optimism in the sense
that —
Kevin Kelly: Yes, yes.
Tim Ferriss: — the belief that you can make
things turn out all right, as opposed to the
belief that things will turn out all right,
and therefore, I can go about my day and not
concern myself with worries about A, B, C,
D, E, all the way through Z, and I'm curious
if you suddenly had The Kevin Kelly Institute
for Active Optimists, how you would cultivate
this, or maybe encourage it in more people
because I do see optimists who are, not panicked,
not necessarily paranoid, but they are very
interested and excited and feel some moral
obligation to focus on really high leverage,
solving really high leverage problems, or
creating new technologies.
I also see techno optimists that are like,
well, if A, B, and C gets bad enough, if the
temperature of the Earth gets to X, Y, and
Z, then we'll have these technologies, it
will all be fine, and if this happens, then
that'll all be fine, and people thought oil
was going to run out by this year, but they
didn't factor in that as the number of barrels
per year produced went down, the price would
go up, and then all these other technologies,
like fracking, became viable, and voila, no
problem.
I view those caps as somewhat different, and
I'm just wondering if you have any perspectives
on that.
Kevin Kelly: I love your distinction between
passive optimism and active.
I think that's brilliant and right on, but
I guess the reality is that you can't be active
about everything.
You have to select —
Tim Ferriss: Totally.
Kevin Kelly: — and choose, and so there
is a sense in which, okay, there is a greater
than zero chance that the Earth could be impacted
by an asteroid, and it would be really devastating,
and one of the most devastating things that
could ever happen to this planet, far beyond,
even with climate change.
And —
Tim Ferriss: It would definitely change the
climate.
Kevin Kelly: Exactly, and very fast, so it's
really good that there is now a group of people
who are thinking about that, and there's the
B1612 Foundation, which is just tracking all
the asteroids, what was it called?
B1612, after The Little Prince.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, got it.
Kevin Kelly: It's a viable thing that they've
been behind all the tracking of all the asteroids
and upping that, and then, recently, we just
sent something that hit the asteroid and deflected,
so that's the first cosmic impact we really
had in the cosmos.
Tim Ferriss: Pretty wild to think, like the
monkeys on a spinning rock —
Kevin Kelly: Exactly.
Right.
Tim Ferriss: — figured out to deflect asteroids.
Kevin Kelly: So it's good that there is a
small group of people, but we don't need to
have that be our concern for making national
policy every year.
Really, that probability is so low, that it
shouldn't really be a factor in us making
our decisions about what we're going to do
this year.
So that's passive, in that sense, but it is,
I can be passive about it because there is
another group of people that is active about
it.
Tim Ferriss: And you know that a group is
active.
Kevin Kelly: Right, so what might help other
people?
I think for me, one of the major things for
me was the more I thought about the future,
the more I became interested in history, and
the more I read history, the more reality
of progress became.
I think just acknowledging the reality of
progress would go a large, huge step in helping
our optimism.
Tim Ferriss: Now, I'm interrupting, not to
push back, but just for definition of terms.
What do you mean by "progress," because that
word can be used to mean in a lot of different
things.
In what sense?
Kevin Kelly: That's right.
It's a very loaded word, and I'm using it
to mean, simply, that —
Tim Ferriss: Angels of our better nature type
stuff?
Kevin Kelly: Yes.
How would I say it?
It means that, overall, on average, this is
a better place to live than at any time in
the past, and this is the kind of Obama test.
I don't know if you've heard about that, but
it's like if you were to be born randomly
in any time period, it could be male, female,
poor, rich, you're totally at random, on some
average thing.
What time do you want to live in?
What time period?
And there's no way you want to be anything
before, at least, 50 years ago, and maybe
not even within 50 years.
So, because we intuitively understand that
this is actually the best time to be alive,
but there is a recognition of, so what are
the currents that made that?
What has allowed that?
What's operating?
Is it still going?
And from my view of history, and I had the
chance to live in the past, and on a time
machine, we'll talk about that in a minute
—
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Wow, I didn't see that coming.
Yes, I got time.
I'm taking note.
Time machine, question mark.
Kevin Kelly: I've been in the time machine
and it's very, very clear that we've been
on a momentum in a trajectory of progress,
and it's possible that could stop tomorrow.
It's highly unlikely that it's going to stop
tomorrow, so there is just, all the conditions
that make that, suggest that it will continue,
and so part of our optimism can come from
that.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Time machine's coming up.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I want people to stick around.
Right after this commercial break, folks.
No, I'm not going to take a commercial break,
but I do want to ask you, given the bet on
collapse of global human population, do you
think that by 2060, if we've peaked out at
the top of the roller coaster, do you think
this progress is inextricably linked to population
growth and population density, and if that's
the case, do you think we might be looking
at regression?
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I'm not trying to turn you to
the dark side.
Kevin Kelly: No, no, no, no.
Tim Ferriss: I'm just curious.
Kevin Kelly: You're doing, you're asking the
exact right question.
I think there's a movement called Degrowth,
the degrowth movement.
Tim Ferriss: I'm not familiar.
Kevin Kelly: So these are people who basically
see the troubles of the world, in particular
the climate one, coming from our addiction
to growth.
That growth, this is kind of the consumer,
capitalistic kind of idea that grow, grow,
grow, grow, and they're saying, it's finite.
We can't continue to grow, and we have to
degrowth, stop growing, and there's a little
bit of a confusion in English because there's
two meanings of the word growth.
There's growth to add more pounds, to add
more and more stuff, to get bigger, wider,
heavier, to have more things, to sell more
refrigerators, to sell more bottles of wine,
but there's another meaning of the word growth,
which is probably closer to what you're interested
in.
Personal growth, developing, maturing —
Tim Ferriss: Or knowledge growth.
Kevin Kelly: Knowledge growth.
Tim Ferriss: I guess, in a sense, it's the
same as the first, but it's —
Kevin Kelly: No, it's increasing its complexity.
Tim Ferriss: Infinite in capacity.
Kevin Kelly: It's taking the same number of
atoms and having a more complex arrangement.
It's going from a jellyfish to a chimpanzee
or something, and so that complex, adaptive
system, where you have increasing levels of
complexity and more exotropy in it, that is
a different kind of growth.
Tim Ferriss: What is exotropy?
Now, I know what entropy is.
Kevin Kelly: It's the opposite.
Tim Ferriss: Exo, like exoskeleton —
Kevin Kelly: Right, so it's the definition
of entropy, right, is increasing disorder,
and then there's something called negative
entropy, which is what I'm talking about.
But that's a double negative.
I don't like double negatives.
So exotropy is basically an increase in order.
So exotropy is this idea of this increasing
order that comes at the cost of increasing
entropy.
So that's the thing.
So you get your system like a living cell
is actually increasing the generation of entropy
as it increases its order.
It's like the magnifying glass with the sun.
You ever seen that?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Kelly: There's a little bright spot
in the middle of a lens in the sun, but all
around it is a shadow.
Because it's taken all the light —
Tim Ferriss: Right, and concentrated it.
Kevin Kelly: From around and concentrated
in.
So there it generates a shadow.
Tim Ferriss: Right, so they go together.
Kevin Kelly: So they go together.
So what type of growth is an increase in complexity?
So you have an economy where instead of trying
to sell more bottles of wine, you try to sell
the same number of wines, but better wine.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Kelly: That's a different kind of growth.
That's the kind of growth that we can shift
into.
So we're just increasing the quality of things.
Tim Ferriss: Do you think there are incentives
that will drive that?
Kevin Kelly: Well, the decreasing population.
Tim Ferriss: How are we going to keep our
revenue numbers the same?
Well, everybody's leaving.
Kevin Kelly: Right.
You have a smaller market every year, a smaller
audience.
So one way is to make things better.
To make better stuff.
Okay.
And we have, so refrigerators, if you just
count how many refrigerators are being sold,
you can have increasing numbers, but you could
sell refrigerators and make them better every
year, which is what we've been doing.
And that's actually not often caught into
the accounted for in economics.
It's just like it's GDP is how many refrigerators
per unit are you making, but they're not saying,
"Well, actually these new refrigerators are
better because they use less energy.
They make ice as well as refrigerate, they
do all these other things."
That's not really accounted for.
And so we can change how we account for things
and we start to measure something different
just other than expansion, the more stuff.
So we need some new metrics.
So yes, I am optimistic that we can change
our understanding and what we aim for.
It's not inevitable though.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Well, time will tell and makes me want to
be a better student of history.
Also, as you pointed out.
Kevin Kelly: So the time machine.
I know that you're going to —
Tim Ferriss: Time machine.
Kevin Kelly: I know you're going to ask about
the time machine.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, it's there.
It's right there at the top right.
Time machine question mark.
For those who think I'm lying.
It's right there.
Okay.
Kevin Kelly: Time machine.
I took a $20 bus ride in northern Afghanistan
in 1975 somewhere.
And I arrived in a different century, literally
in a different century.
I had no map.
I had not met anybody, heard of anybody who
ever went there.
I mean, there was obviously lots of Afghans,
but I mean no tourists.
I had no idea if I could get there.
It was literally a name on a very poor map.
Tim Ferriss: How did you choose it?
Kevin Kelly: It was so remote and I wanted
to see what was at the end of the line.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Kevin Kelly: And here was a town, and I don't
know, maybe there's a hundred thousand people
in this town.
Tim Ferriss: That was a good size.
Kevin Kelly: A good size town.
There was no electricity in the town.
They didn't have street lights.
They would have a guy at night go and light
kerosene lamps, the street lighter.
They would throw their shit into the strait,
I mean out the window kind of stuff.
And of course, there was a futile structure.
I mean, they had basically slaves and child
brides and the whole thing.
It was just medieval in every way.
Very little metal.
There was no signage on the town.
There was no signs.
Didn't need signs.
So it was like, I'm in a different century.
I'm in a different century.
And that experience of seeing what you get
when you had development and technology, and
of course you could see all the challenges
and the problems.
But the main thing that I learned from that
experience is the thing that we get is we
get choices and options.
That's ultimately what we get from the technology.
So the people growing up there had — their
occupations were fated, they were destined.
If you're going to to be male, you're going
to be a farmer, maybe a blacksmith.
If you're a woman, you're going to be a wife
and a mother.
And that was it.
If you took the bus all the way into the city
and went somewhere else, you'd be in a grimy,
gritty slum.
But you had a choice for the first time of
what you could do.
And maybe, not then, but now, if you took
that bus ride, you might be a web manager,
web designer, a yoga teacher, a mortgage broker,
whatever.
You have choices.
And that's what they do not have.
They had very strong family, good identity,
tremendous support, maybe organic food, but
no choices.
Tim Ferriss: AI.
Kevin Kelly: From the 15th century to today.
Tim Ferriss: Even as I understand it, some,
let's call them AI researchers, computer scientists
with familiarity with AI, couldn't have even
predicted several years ago, us having today.
Many choices, maybe some difficult choices,
maybe some difficult outcomes, I might go
so far to say.
And I wanted to read something.
This is from your Wired piece, November, 2022.
And this is after spending months creating
thousands of images using AI, excellent piece.
I think it's limitless creativity.
And there's one line that stuck out to me
and I was like man, that's a strong statement.
I kind of wish Kevin hadn't included this
because I think it's going to be hard to defend
and I would like to talk about it.
And this also pairs with an article I only
started recently reading from Marc Andreessen.
And as I understand it, the basic premise
is that AI will not cause an increase in unemployment.
Which is a bit broader than the line that
we have here.
So let me read it.
"I have spent the past six months using AIs
to create thousands of striking images, often
losing a night’s sleep in the unending quest
to find just one more beauty hidden in the
code.
And after interviewing the creators, power
users, and other early adopters of these generators,
I can make a very clear prediction: Generative
AI will alter how we design just about everything."
Period.
Side note, I completely agree with this.
"Oh, and not a single human artist will lose
their job because of this new technology."
So maybe I should ask you to clarify this,
because I work with tons and tons and tons
of contractors.
And there are artists right now I've worked
with who are going to be replaced.
At least some of their functions will be replaced
by AI.
So I would predict they will lose that specific
job.
Not necessarily with me, but at some point
in the next few years, they will probably
lose that job.
If they have adapted to using the technologies,
I think, or carved a niche for themselves,
they will find another job.
But they will lose jobs.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So how would you expand on this
statement?
Kevin Kelly: There might be a little bit of
semantics here because I would say that it
will replace many tasks, but not their job.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Kelly: So this is what AI does, we replace
tasks.
There are tasks that we do.
Most jobs are complex with different tasks.
And a lot of these tasks will go to the AI,
but not necessarily the job.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Kelly: Because the job will shift and
you'll have different tasks.
Part of that strength is that I would actually
maybe even expand this even broader.
And people, and I welcome feedback on this,
my claim would be that I don't think there's
anybody in any field that's lost their job
because of AI.
So far.
There's tasks that have gone away, but not
jobs.
And a lot of the worry about this AI is what
I call third-person worry.
They're saying, "My job/hobby, I'm not going
to be replaced."
But I can imagine somebody else, or maybe
I can imagine my friend losing it, but I'm
still waiting for someone to say, "I lost
my job."
A real person with a real name who'd lost
their job because of AI.
And so far, I haven't.
I maybe even offer like a $200 bounty if you
could tell me the name, specific person who
lost their job because of AI of any sort.
And it's because —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, why take such a binary
bet?
I know you like these bets.
I would take the opposite side of that bet.
But please continue.
Kevin Kelly: Well, you can take it by giving
a name.
So it's partly —
Tim Ferriss: I just have to fire somebody
and then I can take the $200.
Kevin Kelly: Well, no.
But you're at the AI.
That's what I'm saying, because of AI.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I would've to replace him
with AI.
Kevin Kelly: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And then I can blame it on AI.
Kevin Kelly: Right.
Okay.
And we won't be able to do that right now.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Let's take an example, if I may.
Kevin Kelly: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Logo design.
Tim Ferriss: That is what somebody does day
in, day out.
Kevin Kelly: Right.
Tim Ferriss: They design logos.
And I've gone to some of the logo designers,
AI logo.
There are logo AI designers right now and
they're amazing.
But here's the position, and this is my position
is what we get from these AIs currently right
now, are universal personal interns.
They're intern, they're doing the work of
interns.
Tim Ferriss: UPIs.
Kevin Kelly: UPIs.
Okay.
And they're really amazing, but you have to
check their work.
It's embarrassing to release their work without
improvement.
The intern work.
So I've used these logo AI generators and
I'll work with them over and over again.
And this is what the artist will be doing.
The artist is going to be working with their
interns, generating all these possibilities,
tweaking them.
They're kind of like a director or a conductor.
They're managing the interns and they're not
releasing the intern work unedited, unpolished,
uncurated.
And that's what their new tasks become.
The artists.
Tim Ferriss: I'm not totally convinced, however,
I think that will happen.
But I do think some rank and file will perhaps
need to find new jobs.
At the very least, if someone has AI as the
UPI, I would imagine if you have a brand design
studio that focuses on logos with 30 employees,
some of which are junior, there might be some
shuffle.
But we can — go ahead.
Kevin Kelly: So, I mean there's going to be
a lot of art generated from these entities,
these AIs, and I always want to say plural,
always plural.
There's not one AI.
There's AIs, all different species.
But most of that work is being used for areas
that are blank now, where there is no pictures,
where there isn't anything.
So I have, my assistant actually has for years
woken up in the middle of the night to write
her dreams down.
And now she feeds those dreams into the AI
and she illustrates them.
And they're just amazing.
There were no illustrations before.
Now they're illustrations.
Tim Ferriss: Yup.
Kevin Kelly: I used them to generate images
for my slides.
There were no pictures before.
Now there are pictures.
So it's not like I'm replacing somebody —
Tim Ferriss: It's not a zero sum.
Kevin Kelly: I'm filling it in.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Kelly: So the major, and by the way,
there's about 30 million brand new, never-seen-before
images generated every day with these image
generators. 30 million.
And I would say about maybe 95 percent or
maybe 98 percent of them, there's an audience
of one.
It's for the pure pleasure of seeing this.
It's like you would take a walk out into nature
and just see a beautiful scene.
It's like, "I'm just enjoying this."
This is why they're mostly being generated.
The predominant number of them, just because
they're beautiful.
Okay?
And so they weren't there before.
You could not have your own private museum
of these really cool images, maybe no one
will ever see again.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Kelly: Okay.
And so that's what they're being mostly used
for is filling in the blank spaces.
And that's also true, again, of a lot of the
other intern work that may be writing things
that nobody else but the boss sees.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Let's look at this a little more closely.
So I will say, just as a means of setting
the table, I'm deeply, deeply interested in
these tools, which is why, and the effects
that they will have on the creative economies,
the economy period, broadly speaking, society.
I think they're very underestimated.
Kevin Kelly: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And I'd love to get your take
on that in a bit.
I've run AI art competitions related to some
of the fiction that I've put out and have
been absolutely blown away.
I also sympathize with some artists, say on
ArtStation or DeviantArt, who are part of
the training set who are popularly mimicked,
right?
Prompt, yada, yada, yada.
In the style of, fill in the blank.
And I can understand why these artists would
be upset, feel threatened, maybe be financially
impacted.
I imagine their commission work might be.
How do you think that'll shake out?
And I know based on some of the conversations
that we've had, that I believe your perspective
is if people are relevant, they're going to
be copied anyway, right?
Kevin Kelly: Mm-hmm.
Tim Ferriss: And if they're not, it doesn't
really matter if they're in the training data.
Something along those lines.
And so Picasso's influence is going to be
seen all over the place no matter what.
But how do you think this will shake out in
the next handful of years?
Because I understand why people would have
an aversion as artists.
Kevin Kelly: Sure, sure.
So I think there will be people, companies
who will make training sets.
They're all opt-in in some capacity, maybe
most of it's already out of copyright.
And they'll be sold as greenwashes, ethical
training sets, whatever it is.
Tim Ferriss: Fair trade AI artwork.
Kevin Kelly: Exactly.
And then there could be a lot of them where
people will use it.
They'll train the things on their own work.
Like, help me make more images in my style.
Tim Ferriss: I am doing some experiments with
that right now.
Kevin Kelly: Exactly.
And then there's going to be this ability
over time to require less of a training set.
For right now we can, only way we train these
is the more, the billions, the better.
But a human toddler can learn the difference
between a cat and a dog just with 12 examples.
And when we start to have more targeted like
that, I think people will start to clamor
to be included in the training set.
Tim Ferriss: What needs to happen for the
AIs to require far fewer examples in these
training data sets?
Kevin Kelly: We don't know.
That's the short answer.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
But we suspect it's inevitable.
Kevin Kelly: Well, we have existence proof
because we have toddlers.
Tim Ferriss: Toddlers.
Kevin Kelly: So many.
But it may require, right now there's kind
of a brute force, these neuralnets.
Brute force meaning that they're very flat
and they didn't work in the beginning because
they weren't big enough.
And the bigger we make them, they seem to
overcome a lot of the problems.
But it's really clear to most people that
we can't get all the way to where we want
to go just with these flat.
Because these models, basically they do one
or one and a half things.
They do pattern recognition and pattern generation.
That's all.
They don't do symbolic logic, inductive reasoning.
Current ones aren't capable of that.
Tim Ferriss: Irony.
Tough.
Kevin Kelly: Irony.
It's just amazing that they have gone as far
as they have, and we keep expecting that they
can't go any further.
But they keep surprising us.
But we're pretty sure that they can't go all
the way.
And the example I would use is Wikipedia.
Wikipedia is a flat, the idea was flat.
It comes up from the bottom, it's bottom-up.
It's like how far can you make it reliable,
an encyclopedia just from the bottom-up?
Well, a lot farther than you would initially
thought.
But we also know that Wikipedia has succeeded
because in recent years has been more top-down
control of the editors.
And you have to have for ultimately what you
want a combination of mostly bottom-up that's
somewhat regulated by some top-down control,
editorial control, all that kind of stuff.
And that's what we don't really have in AI
right now.
We have just the bottom-up.
It's very, very bottom-up.
And there is just a suspicion looking at the
Santa Fe work on complex adaptive systems
that you will want to have some top-down governance
to assist this bottom-up to get where you
want to go.
Tim Ferriss: You've interviewed just about
everybody.
You can get to just about everybody.
And I know you've spoken to the who's who
of AI and any adjacent field that you want
to investigate.
You know lot of people.
And you know a lot of people that know a lot
of people that know a lot of people.
So you've spoken to so many.
And you have, I would say, one of the more
impressive Nostradamus-like predictive track
records.
What would be your predictions, speculations
within the next five to 10 years?
Could be a shorter timeframe of what you think.
Kevin Kelly: In AI?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
So here's what I would expect.
The thing I want to emphasize is that there's
plural, there's AIs.
So this idea of the monolithic AI taking over,
they're like machines and they follow the
general engineering maxim, which is that you
cannot optimize everything.
There's always trade-offs.
So we're going to engineer these AIs to be
good for certain things, but not as good as
something else in another dimension.
And we already see that with say, the image
generators, some favor artists, some favor
photography.
There'll be different personalities.
The one that does painting the best probably
isn't going to be the best for writing.
They'll be some kind of transformative —
Tim Ferriss: They're all equally bad at hands,
I've noticed.
Kevin Kelly: Right.
And so I say that the general stance we're
going to have is what I call dumbsmarten.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Kelly: They'll be really smarten.
Tim Ferriss: Is that Pennsylvanian Dutch?
Kevin Kelly: I don't know.
It's kind of like that.
It's Amish.
It's dumbsmarten.
We're just going to be furious.
It's like, how could you be so dumb when you're
so smart about these other things?
This is going to be their typical reaction.
It's like, you're insanely brilliant, but
you're so dumb here.
Tim Ferriss: Sounds like half of Silicon Valley.
Kevin Kelly: Exactly.
dumbsmarten is going to be engineered and
we'll have multiple, so it'll be more and
more difficult to kind of generalize.
But what I'm saying is that they're going
to be engineered for specific tasks primarily.
And there will be a general one, but the general
one would be kind of like the Swiss Army knife.
It's like good generally, but not really the
best in any one tool.
That's the engineering maxim.
And so we should expect multiple varieties
of these.
And I think the other thing is that they're
the best, for me, the best stance is to think
of them as artificial aliens.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Kelly: Aliens meaning they could be
like Spock or Yoda.
Very, very smart, but they're just doing things
differently than we would do.
If they have a sense of humor, it'll be a
little off.
But that is actually their benefit.
The benefit is because they help us think
different, and that's what we're going to
be using them for.
That's what people are already using them
for, is generate ideas.
There's probably an idea that no human would
ever come up with.
And that helps me come up with a new idea.
So that stance of — and then the third thing
I would say about the AIs is that most of
them will be unseen.
They'll be behind the office operating things.
The plumbing, the infrastructure.
And that's actually a sign of their success.
Technologies succeed when we don't see them
anymore, we don't think about them.
They become boring and that the majority of
the stuff won't even be outward-facing.
It'll be just behind the scenes.
And then this idea of consciousness, consciousness
is a liability.
You don't want your car to be conscious.
You want it to drive.
You don't want to be worrying about whether
it should major in finance, you want it to
focus on the road.
So there will be advertising AIs as conscious-free,
right?
So there are certain —
Tim Ferriss: Dumb and obedient.
Kevin Kelly: Yes, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Extra $30 per month.
Kevin Kelly: Right.
Exactly.
So I think that I would say a couple things.
One is I think AI overall is underhyped, but
the current version, we won't even call AI
in 30 years.
We'll look back and that wasn't it.
So it means that there's no AI experts right
now.
So I think, but in the short term, we're probably
overestimating this idea, the vast unemployment
stuff.
Not in the next couple of years for sure.
Tim Ferriss: So everything you've said makes
sense and —
Kevin Kelly: Right, right.
Tim Ferriss: Tools will get specialized.
They will become so embedded that we will
cease to think about them.
Kevin Kelly: Hopefully.
Tim Ferriss: Hopefully, right, in the same
way that you waved at the lights, we have
all sorts of lights in here.
But it's not like we walk into any room with
artificial light and we think, "Good Lord!"
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: "What is this miracle of engineering?"
Kevin Kelly: Right, right.
Tim Ferriss: "And human ingenuity."
I think most folks would be like, okay, okay,
so why is it underhyped, right?
What should surprise people or what are people
not appreciating?
Kevin Kelly: Well, so I was involved with
the internet.
I was living online for at least 10 years
before 1992, '93 when wires started.
And in a certain sense, it was like we couldn't
get anybody to just take it seriously.
It was dismissed as teenage boy stuff.
And it was kind of that's what it was.
But I felt like, no, this is really significant.
This is really powerful.
And what changed it was an interface change,
became visual for the first time in the web
was pictures and stuff.
And that's when everybody switched on.
Most of the AI happening today has been happening
for years.
What's new is that we now have an interface.
We have the conversational, it's this idea
of the large language model.
We have a conversational interface.
And that suddenly was oh, the power that's
been there for years is now suddenly accessible.
It's like having the pictures on the web.
And so we're suddenly thinking about it, suddenly
in people's faces in the same way that the
internet was completely fringe.
And then when the web came along, it very
rapidly became mainstream.
I remember the first time I saw my gas station,
the pump, there was like a URL.
I was like "Oh, my gosh, this is like, it's
here."
I have the same feeling right now happening
with the chat bots and the image generators
is these capabilities have been around for
at least a decade.
But now what's new is we have a language interface,
a conversational interface with them.
And the power's just sort of completely in
our faces now.
And so where do we go from there?
I think we are going to then start to apply
this to everything.
It's going to be, I mean, as we speak every
day there's people embedding this and they're
going to embed it with this interface.
So I think we're going to move to this having
a whole 'nother level of interfacing with
this machine with language.
And that's very, very powerful.
We'll just go through the whole thing.
It's like take X, add the language interface
to it.
That's really powerful.
Tim Ferriss: What are you hoping to use AIs
for over the next six to 12 months?
Kevin Kelly: So first of all, I generate,
post an AI picture every day.
I have been for —
Tim Ferriss: When did you switch from manual
to AI?
Kevin Kelly: Last June, almost a year ago.
And —
Tim Ferriss: Which tools do you mostly use?
Kevin Kelly: I tend to go to Midjourney still.
Midjourney for those who don't, has a very
curious interface.
It's a Discord channel.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Kelly: And at first I was completely
bamboozled and infuriated with that, but I
came to see it as genius.
Tim Ferriss: Why is that?
Kevin Kelly: Because everybody's working in
the open.
It's like the ultimate learning vehicle.
And I learn something every time I go on.
Tim Ferriss: Being a student in the surgery
theater back in the day.
Kevin Kelly: Exactly.
You're seeing how other people do it.
It's not behind closed doors.
They're doing it in public.
And oh, my gosh, you learn so much that way.
So fast.
And what's interesting, the year before that,
I did a piece of art every day on my iPad
with Procreate.
And I spent almost as much time on the AIs
making an image as I do when I make it myself.
Because again, the accusation among the painters
in the 1800s when the photography came along
was, "Oh, you guys, you just push the button."
And we realize of course now, that photography
is not just pushing the button.
There's a lot more involved in making a really
great photograph than just pushing the button.
You have to be in the right position and all
this kind of stuff.
And the same thing with the AI art.
It's all, "You're just clicking."
No, no.
It's like photography.
I feel I have some of the same kind of a stance
that I have and I'm photographing, I'm kind
of hunting, searching through it, I'm trying
to find a good position, a good area where
there's kind of promise.
And I'm moving around and I'm trying, and
I'm whispering to the AI, how about this?
I'm changing the word order.
I'm actually interacting, having a conversation
with it over time.
And it might take a half hour or more to get
an image that I am happy with.
And I'm at that point, very comfortable in
putting my name as a co-creator of it because
I have, me and the intern have worked together
to make this thing.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so you have the art application.
Any other applications?
Kevin Kelly: In the future?
In the next six months.
I'm actually using the chatbots to help write.
Tim Ferriss: Chatbots.
ChatGPT.
Kevin Kelly: Yes, ChatGPT, Bing, and stuff,
and Google.
For me, I've always had problems making that
first draft.
It's just a killer.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
And I know the feeling.
Kevin Kelly: You know the feeling.
I find it helpful in making the first draft.
Tim Ferriss: How do you prompt it?
What would be an example approach?
Kevin Kelly: All different ways.
And I've been collecting this.
And here's the thing about —
Tim Ferriss: Your book of spells.
Kevin Kelly: Yes.
Here's the thing about it, is that this is
an important lesson about technology, is that
we have to use it to figure it out.
There's something I call thinkism, which is
this reliance on trying to solve problems
by thinking about them, which is very appealing
to people who like to think.
And you can only go so far with thinkism because
all the things we're discovering about this,
none of the inventors of this had any idea
that they could be used this way.
Tim Ferriss: That's cool.
Kevin Kelly: Right?
And so we're discovering, we collectively,
by using it are discovering its capabilities
and eventually its harms.
But that's important because this is how we
steer the things.
And so the problem with trying to prohibit
or turn it off or ban it, is that you don't
get to steer anything.
Going back to that metaphor.
So right now through use we're uncovering
all these things.
And I've been trying to track how people are
actually using them.
For instance, chats.
There's a couple prompts.
So here's the thing, these chat models, basically
what they generate are wisdom of the crowd
kind of knowledge.
The wisdom of the crowd is very famous, counting
the jelly beans.
If you average all the attempts by humans
to count the number of the jelly beans in
a bottle, the best guess, the most accurate,
was the average of it.
And that's what we're getting with the chat.
It's taking everything as written, the plus
and the minuses, the geniuses and the jerks,
and it's averaging out.
And that's what it's giving you is an average.
So most of the content generated by the chats
is broadly correct, very average, very bland.
And a lot of what you're doing with the intern
is pressing them.
So one of the tricks is that you can ask for
it to be a little bit snarkier or more professional.
Tim Ferriss: So let's say you're starting
tabula rasa.
Idea popped into your head in the shower.
Okay, I want to give a rough draft a shot.
What is the step number one, step number two?
Kevin Kelly: So it depends, but I might ask
it to do a summary of what's known about this.
Tell me everything that it knows about it.
And then maybe write a first draft with bullets,
five bullet points.
And then I might —
Tim Ferriss: Could you give a real example
or a example you might use?
Kevin Kelly: I'm trying to think of the last
one I did.
Tim Ferriss: How the Egyptians influenced
Roman architecture.
I don't know, making that up.
Kevin Kelly: Exactly right.
You could do that.
Give me the five bullet points and stuff.
And then you could have questions about some
parts you didn't understand or expand bullet
one citing more sources or give me an example
of a day in the life of this or 10 more examples
of how this might play out.
You could expand it that way.
You could also shrink it in terms of summarizing,
making bullet points or what's the key takeaway
or how about if I wanted to have a teachable
moment out of this.
And so you would have all these kinds of things
flowing around.
And then, again, it's the intern at work.
It's good but you're not going to use it.
You're probably rewriting it.
It maybe gives me some ideas I didn't have
or maybe the structure of how it organized
it, that's pretty good for four of them.
And so it's a start.
And for me —
Tim Ferriss: It gets you past the breath hold
of the empty page.
Kevin Kelly: For me, this is really big, this
is getting going.
And then you can also use it later on.
I have a friend who writes scripts and they
do, "Show me all the weak plot points in this
or…"
Tim Ferriss: Could you explain that?
Kevin Kelly: You put the script in and they'll
say, "What are some of the contradictory plot
points?"
Tim Ferriss: That's a great use.
Kevin Kelly: Right.
Just another set of eyes.
Tim Ferriss: Thinking about fiction, you could
find internal inconsistencies.
Kevin Kelly: Internal inconsistencies or where's
continuity broken or things like that.
Or you also could — here's something I used,
my book, which we'll get to, my publisher
asked for talking points.
So I said, "Make a list of nine talking points
for this book."
Tim Ferriss: Time machine number one.
Woolly mammoth number two.
Kevin Kelly: It made a good list.
Again, I didn't, couldn't really use the list,
but I could use it to make the list.
Tim Ferriss: It was a starting point.
Kevin Kelly: It was a starting point.
And here's another thing.
So I have a friend who has a blog, a daily
blog, they generate 40 posts a day.
Tim Ferriss: I can probably guess who this
is.
Kevin Kelly: Probably guess who it is.
Tim Ferriss: 400?
I was like, "That's a lot."
Kevin Kelly: 40 a day.
So they use it to help write headlines.
They'll give the thing — they'll say, "Give
me five headlines."
Tim Ferriss: Now I've actually not used, say,
ChatGPT for this.
There's an upload function where you can upload
your document and then use that as the basis
or part of the basis for the prompt.
Kevin Kelly: Yes.
Write some headlines.
He says this is really, really good with suggesting
something that they hadn't thought of.
Or he said, also, sometimes he'll give it
the posting, and said, "Give me a great punchline
at the end."
Tim Ferriss: That's cool.
Kevin Kelly: And again, it's the intern.
They're pretty good.
Tim Ferriss: It's going to give you something,
though.
Kevin Kelly: Give you something to start with.
Tim Ferriss: I'll give you an example from
my own life, just for fun.
A friend of mine suggested this because he
sent me a text, he said, "This is pretty interesting."
And he used ChatGPT, he's been exploring all
these tools in great depth and I've played
with a lot of them, but not in the depth that
he has.
And he had suggested a podcast guest, John
Vervaeke, who was on not too long ago, and
he simply put in a prompt along the lines
of, "What are questions that Tim Ferriss might
ask John Vervaeke on his podcast in the style
of Tim Ferriss?"
And they weren't perfectly polished, but they
were not bad.
Kevin Kelly: Right?
Exactly.
Not bad is, I think, the title.
I mean, that's what we're talking about.
It's a not-bad intern.
Tim Ferriss: Right?
Kevin Kelly: Okay.
It's a not-bad intern, it's a universal, not-bad
personal intern.
They'll get better.
And I think also, again, they'll get specialized.
So in 15 years, 15 years —
so here's my reluctance about that.
I saw VR for the first time, Jaron Lanier
in 1989, '87.
I
could see that in five years.
I mean, it was so good.
It was so amazing.
Tim Ferriss: "We'll be at Ready Player One
in 1992."
Kevin Kelly: Exactly.
So what's happened in the 30 years since then?
The state of the Oculus, whatever, it is about
the same as what I saw with Jaron Lanier.
But it's a million times cheaper.
But it really isn't a million times better.
So I don't know, I think this is the time
for scenarios.
I think I could have bunch of different scenarios
rather than making a prediction.
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Great.
Kevin Kelly: And one of the scenarios is that
it doesn't get exponentially better, but it
just gets exponentially pervasive.
Tim Ferriss: Which you would think would automatically
— not automatically, that's a strong word,
would make it better in terms of access to
larger data sets?
Kevin Kelly: Yes, again, I think one of the
things that might come — we might have a
much more tailored version of this.
So going back to your attempts to train it
on your own stuff or to maybe have a more
customized version of stuff that you want.
So it's maybe relatively the same level, but
it's much more personalized and tailored and
customized to what you do and how you do it.
And also —
Tim Ferriss: Also tailored for my audience.
And I've already seen a few people do this
because my transcripts are available on the
website.
I want to train an AI on my transcripts and
also a lot of material that I produce so that
the most common questions I get can be sourced
from actual answers I've given.
Kevin Kelly: So I have a doctor friend who
runs a popular pediatrician site, ask the
doctor these questions, and he has trained
it on all his 20 years of answering questions
to his patients to do a chat.
And it works pretty good.
And it's, as they say, better than no doctor.
And that's literally trained on his replies.
And I think more of that will be coming, even
better.
So whether we get to the point where we can
do the deductive reasoning of the transfer
learning, I don't know, because we haven't
really seen that much.
So that's one scenario, is we suddenly make
another big innovation leap and we have another
— besides just being able to synthesize
pattern stuff, we can actually do these other
kinds of cognition.
That would be huge.
But there's no evidence that that's going
on.
So another scenario is just that we have more
of this on a larger scale, more pervasive,
more tailorised, like in the way that, I don't
know, there's probably been no real advances
in social media in the 10 years it's been
around.
Tim Ferriss: All right, excellent advice for
[inaudible].
Damn it, Kevin, I've been trying to get you
to talk about this and you keep pushing back.
I was going to segue to this because you mentioned
using AI to think differently, as a catalyst
for thinking differently.
And it made me think of advice that I've certainly
read of yours and we've probably had conversations
about it, which related to career advice for
people, say, in their twenties and exploring
avenues and creating for themselves or attempting
to create for themselves jobs and activities
that don't have clear labels.
And using that, among other tools, as a way
to learn to think differently.
But let's zoom out.
So I'm holding two copies of the book.
One is very, very tiny.
This is a prized possession, now.
I've read it probably 12 times.
I have many, many notes and there are all
sorts of notes in here.
Excellent Advice for Living.
Now the tiny version I have says, "Seeds for
contemplation," which I also like.
And then there's the very beautiful cover
of this galley that you handed to me just
before we started recording.
Excellent Advice for Living: Wisdom I Wish
I’d Known Earlier.
How did this come to be?
What is the genesis story?
Kevin Kelly: So I would write down bits of
advice to help me change my own behavior.
I like to reduce something that I could say
to myself, to repeat to myself, to remember
something as a way of changing my behavior.
And that kind of encapsulation and reduction
to a little tiny sentence, for me, it was
a handle to grab hold of it and bring it forth
when I needed it.
And an example would be if I know I have something
in my household and I can't find it, then
when I finally do find it, I'd say to myself,
when I'm getting ready to put it back, "Don't
put it back where I found it, put it back
where I first looked for it."
So I had my flashlight, "Put it back where
you first looked for it."
So I'm reminding myself that.
And so I would start to write things down.
Another one would be if I'm invited to do
a talk or go meet somebody or have coffee,
whatever it is, I would say to myself, "Would
I do this if it was tomorrow morning?"
As kind of a filter to really make sure it
passed that hurdle, because eventually it
will be tomorrow morning and I have to think
about it.
And so I would say, "I got this invite.
Well that's kind of interesting, good.
But would I do this tomorrow morning?"
So making it into some portable way that I
could remind myself very easily.
And I start to get in the habit of writing
these down and I realized a lot of it was
advice that I wish I had known earlier.
I have three kids.
And the way of our parenting was the opposite
of helicopter parenting, was very hands off.
And we did not give them much advice ever.
When I was growing up, I didn't really pay
attention to what my parents said, I paid
attention to what they did.
And I figured that's what our kids were doing
too.
So we try to model behavior rather than to
say it.
So neither my wife or I have ever really gave
much advice, but I thought that now that I
was writing it down that I should give them
advice.
So I began this idea of trying to extract
out and put into a little handle of something
encapsulated that I could give to my kids.
I did a bunch when I was 68.
On my birthday I released it to my son at
that time, who was a young adult, just becoming
a young adult.
And a lot of people loved it and it ricocheted
around the internet.
I did it for a couple more years and I realized
that I had a lot to say.
I was finally giving advice that I'd been
giving myself —
Tim Ferriss: Bottled up for all these decades.
Kevin Kelly: — for 70 years.
I was giving it out.
But it's scattered around the internet.
And I thought it would be really handy to
have it in a book.
So I made a prototype myself, just made a
little book.
I made five copies and I sent it around to
see if it worked as a book.
And this book also has my little doodles in
it.
And it worked.
And so I sent it to a publisher, they loved
it.
They said they didn't like the doodles, and
so they said, "No art by you."
So it's in a portable form.
And actually I realized afterwards, although
it was not in my head at the time, but it's
very tweetable.
These are tweets.
And so they work at the attention span of
a young person these days and they transmit
well.
And so the version you have here has about
another hundred that aren't even in this —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, look at this.
So just when I thought Christmas was far away.
Kevin Kelly: I tried to make them as practical
as possible, actionable, not conventional,
positive, if at all possible, and short.
"You can find no better medicine for your
family than regular meals together without
screens."
Tim Ferriss: Let me throw a few out just because
I have so many notes in here.
So I'll mention a couple and one that I may
not get verbatim, but I've thought quite a
bit about, because when I look back at all
the places I've spent time, it's totally true.
It's something like if an outdoor patio is
less than six feet wide, no one will ever
use it.
Kevin Kelly: A balcony.
No one will use a balcony unless it's —
Tim Ferriss: Never, ever.
Kevin Kelly: Never.
Tim Ferriss: And I thought about it, I was
like, "That a hundred percent maps to all
of my experience."
So we have, "What you do on your bad days
matters more than what you do on your good
days."
This also overlaps with a lot of my thoughts
on ritual and routine versus relying on, say,
discipline.
"Greatness is incompatible with optimizing
in the short term," and it goes on and on.
I'm just mentioning a few that I've highlighted
for myself.
"You don't marry a person, you marry a family."
That's a big one.
Kevin Kelly: I decided you don't marry a family,
you marry a country because my wife is from
a different country.
Tim Ferriss: And who knows, maybe a hundred
years from now you don't marry a person, you
marry a planet, a species.
"If you can't tell what you desperately need,
it's probably sleep."
"Don't aim to have others like you, aim to
have them respect you," which also helps in
saying no to things that you won't want to
do tomorrow morning.
Are there any that come to mind for you — here
it is, "A balcony or porch needs to be at
least six feet deep or it won't be used."
Then there are some very, very specific recommendations.
"Learn to tie a bowline knot.
Practice in the dark with one hand for the
rest of your life.
You'll use this knot more times than you could
ever believe."
True.
I only learned that knot, I want to say, in
2012, and I've used it a million times since.
What are some here that people have responded
particularly well to?
Are there any that pop out, that come to mind?
I'll buy you some time.
"When you feel pressure to pick a choice,
don't forget the choice of not choosing any."
That's one I starred for myself.
Kevin Kelly: One thing that has surprised
me is that there've been no overlap in people's
favorites.
No overlaps in people's favorites.
I don't know what to make of that.
But anyway, that's what it is.
So I'll tell you some of my favorites.
When you're in your twenties you should spend
a little bit of time doing something that's
sort of crazy, insane, unprofitable, unorthodox,
orthogonal, because that's going to be your
touchstone and the foundation of your success
later on.
Try and deliberately — don't try for something
successful or creative.
Do something very, very strange and weird.
It's kind of like to the other bit of advice
of the thing that made you weird as a kid
can make you great as an adult if you don't
lose it.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Kevin Kelly: I mean, this is very true.
Tim Ferriss: It's true.
It's very true.
Very true.
Kevin Kelly: So one of my favorite bits of
advice that can be expanded, which is, "Don't
aim to be the best.
Be the only."
Tim Ferriss: Category of one.
Kevin Kelly: Here's the category of one.
Right before us you are living that.
Even though if 10 years ago, I don't know
when you started your podcast —
Tim Ferriss: Almost 10.
It'll be 10 years next year.
Kevin Kelly: You want to be doing something
where it's hard to explain to your mother
what it is that you do.
So it's like, "What is it?
Well, it's not quite radio.
I don't know.
It's like talking."
And so that's where you want to be.
You want to be the only.
You want to — and that's a very high bar
because it requires a tremendous amount of
self-knowledge and awareness to get to that
point, to really understand what it is that
you do better than anybody else in the world.
And for most of us, it takes all our lives
to figure that out.
And we also, by the way, need family, friends,
colleagues, customers, clients, everyone around
us to help us understand what it is that we
do better than anybody else because we can't
really get there by yourself.
You can't do thinkism, you can't figure your
way there, you have to try and live it out.
And that's why most people's remarkable lives
are full of detours and dead ends and right
turns because it's a very high bar.
But if you can get there — you don't need
a resume, there's no competition.
And it's easy for you because you're doing
it.
You're not looking over your shoulder, you're
just right there.
So don't aim to be the best.
Be the only.
Tim Ferriss: On the easy front, a question
that I've sometimes asked my friends because
the things that are right in front of us all
the time are sometimes the hardest to see
—
Kevin Kelly: There you go.
Tim Ferriss: — is what do you think is easy
for me that is harder for other people?
Because sometimes you take, I shouldn't say
— oftentimes take it for granted because
it's just what you do and you don't even see
where you have something that falls into that
category.
Kevin Kelly: I actually use that, in a similar
form of the question, at dinner parties when
I'm sitting next to a buddy.
So one of my bits of advice is that almost
everybody knows a lot more about something
than anybody else around them.
And so I'll sit down, it's like, "What do
you know more about than most people?"
And I feel it's my job to find out what that
is.
And it's not obvious, it's not always obvious,
you have to work at it, but it's always amazing.
Tim Ferriss: Yes, totally.
Kevin Kelly: If you can get there, they know
something that'll just blow your mind.
And so that's my assignment when I go to a
party.
That person knows an amazing amount of something,
but it's not going to be obvious, but they'll
tell me.
Tim Ferriss: I have a close cousin of that
that I sometimes use myself, which is once
someone has shared, or maybe it's already
known what they do professionally, their primary
gig, let's just say it's finance in some capacity.
And I might just ask — could be anything
though, doesn't matter.
And I would just ask, "If you had to give
a TED Talk, 20 minutes long, but it couldn't
be on anything that people at this table know
you for, including finance, what would it
be on?"
And you get some of the most out-of-left-field
responses and it opens the floodgates to a
really interesting conversation.
I'm going to mention a couple more.
"Your enjoyment of travel is inversely proportional
to the size of your luggage."
This is 100 percent true of backpacking.
It is liberating to realize how little you
really need.
And if people are not familiar with our first
conversation, they should listen to it and
they will realize that you walk the walk with
that.
You have certainly walked the walk with that
and are minimalist in so many ways.
I want to ask a follow-up question to one
of these.
"For the best results with your children,"
I starred this one, "Spend only half the money
you think you should, but double the time
with them."
One of the letters, I don't get a lot of physical
letters, but one of the letters that I most
look forward to every year, I think it's your
year in review or Christmas perhaps, but you
give a recap and you talk about the family
and adventures and so on.
What have you found to be some of the best
investments of time with your kids?
Because abstractly I bet most parents would
nod their heads and say, "Of course, that
makes sense.
Absolutely."
But not all ways of spending time with kids
are equal, I would imagine.
For building intimacy and a relationship with
your kids or maybe other things, what have
you found to be really good uses of time?
Kevin Kelly: I don't know enough about this
generally, but I can only tell you what we
have done ourselves.
And for me —
Tim Ferriss: That's what I'm asking.
Kevin Kelly: For me, what I've seen is a couple
things.
One is making things together.
I'm a maker and so I have to work against
my better instincts to be too involved or
take over too much, but to really allow that
cooperative, joint, making together.
And it's fun for the kid and it's fun for
me.
And you get to see frustrations, overcoming
frustrations, making mistakes, overcoming
mistakes.
So there's a tremendous amount going on, both
of them learning and me learning about them.
And that togetherness is really great.
Tim Ferriss: What kind of stuff have you made
together?
Kevin Kelly: We've made go karts, we've made
gingerbread castles, we've made Styrobot.
I don't know if you — one of my all time
favorites was making Styrobot with my son.
Tim Ferriss: I remember Styrobot.
Kevin Kelly: It was made from recycled styrofoam.
It's nine feet tall.
Just art projects, helping in the garden,
doing chores together.
I would say travel is undoubtedly one of the
best learning experiences, so much that I
think as a nation we should subsidize travel,
but as a family, if you can afford it.
And I don't mean that it's going on vacation,
the kind of travel I like is where you are
learning.
It's like a learning experience, it's an experience
and oh, my gosh, is that so powerful.
And I would say one thing about it, that I've
learned doing it, and that is that I was a
little concerned when we were doing very intense
travel with my kids at a younger age, they,
at times, didn't seem to be paying attention.
They seemed not to be aware, or they were
maybe wanting to stay in the hotel and play
cards or things like that when we were in
Tibet, whatever.
But later on I found out that actually they
were paying attention, but they couldn't process
it at the time.
So the experience was there and they would
reprocess it over time and it would become
more and more valuable as they had more and
more to interpret it.
And that trip, which I thought was a failure
at the time, because they were not really
appreciating it, but actually grew in importance.
And so don't be dismayed if you take your
kids on a great adventure and they're kind
of not impressed or they're not changed or
whatever.
No, no, no.
They haven't yet been able to process it and
they'll process it over time.
Tim Ferriss: Any other tips for traveling
with kids?
Because I can imagine a family trip that it
is, well, certainly very different from a
Kevin Kelly family trip where a family has
gone to five countries, they've stayed in
the Four Seasons in each one, the kids have
been on their phones the entire time.
And you can fill in the rest of the picture.
So what would be perhaps some recommendations?
And I'm not saying people should sleep on
the sidewalks, just you can travel and not
actually leave the comfort of your own usual
scaffolding.
Kevin Kelly: Yes, no.
One of the bits of advice is like, "A vacation
plus a disaster equals an adventure."
One of the times I rode my bicycle across
the US was from Vancouver down to Mexico on
the coast.
And I rode with my son who was a teenager,
and I had his nephew who was a teenager along.
That was an incredible experience.
And doing that together, like an adventure
together, was tremendous for them because
it took them out of the San Francisco bubble
and they could see the real world.
And again, it was a learning experience about
overcoming, doing things that seemed hard,
but turned out to be things that you just
could do.
So I would say yes, try new things.
Another thing that I think is really good
for travel is to almost go somewhere at random.
I mean literally.
So our policy for our family was to follow
passions and interests rather than destinations.
So every kid, we would say, "We're going to
follow your passion for our vacation this
year.
Whatever you're interested in."
If you were interested Ann of Green Gables,
okay, we're going to go to Nova Scotia and
visit all the Anne of Green Gables sites.
If your kid —
Tim Ferriss: What is Anne of Green Gables?
I probably should know.
Kevin Kelly: Anne of Green Gables is a popular
children's or young adults' story.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Kevin Kelly: Anne of Green Gables.
And there's a series of books and it was based
in Nova Scotia and there's kind of a big following
about that.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Kevin Kelly: So our son was interested in
dinosaurs when he was very little.
Okay.
We're going to go to all the dinosaur digs
and dinosaur museums and dinosaur excavations
we could find.
And that was the theme.
And they were very engaged in that vacation.
We were in an RV and we're going around visiting
dinosaurs because that was — so the child
got to pick.
Tim Ferriss: So the follow-up question I had
after the bicycle story was whether your kids
have always been game for these adventures,
or whether you've cultivated/Jedi mind-tricked
them into being more game?
Because I would have to imagine, this is speculation,
but there are parents listening and they're
like, "I could never convince my teenage…"
Kevin Kelly: Oh, I see.
Tim Ferriss: "...son to go cycling for weeks
at a time or months at a time," whatever it
might be.
And maybe that's just out of the box —
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
No —
Tim Ferriss: — they've been ready to go.
Kevin Kelly: I guess I would say, it was not
an issue that we had.
Yeah, they were always up for it, particularly,
again, if you have something that's surrounding
their own passion.
Tim Ferriss: I was imagining that if you've
— what's the right term?
If you folded them into the process of making
these decisions from an early age, they relate
to these things differently than if —
Kevin Kelly: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: — everything has been an assignment.
Kevin Kelly: Right.
So I think that's how you do it.
It is an extension.
And we homeschooled our son for one year and
part of that home year of homeschooling, we
weren't home, we were traveling.
And again, it was this idea of, "Where would
you like to go?
You get to set some of the things."
And that was total engagement.
You want to make sure that it's —
Tim Ferriss: You're invested.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah, you're invested.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
I'm going to grab a few more here.
"If an elementary school student is struggling,
first thing, check their eyesight."
Good advice, something I need to get checked
'cause my family has quite a bit of glaucoma
and intraocular pressure issues and I haven't
had them checked in a long time, so I'll get
there.
"Purchase the most recent tourist guidebook
to your hometown or region.
You'll learn a lot by playing the tourist
once a year."
This is something I did.
I went out and I actually got the guide books.
And you do pick up a lot.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: You pick up a lot.
I did this in San Francisco too.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: It's shocking how much you miss.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I remember growing up in New
York, I never made it to the Statue of Liberty
or the Empire State Building until a German
friend visited me 10 years ago and was shocked
that I had never been to either of these things.
And I was like, "You know, maybe I should
at least spend an afternoon and go see these
things."
And it was a blast.
It was a lot of fun.
Kevin Kelly: One Thanksgiving day we went
into San Francisco and rode the cable cars,
which we had never been on.
And it was the perfect day because there was
nobody else on them for Thanksgiving day.
And so, yes, it's a way of, again, I favor
things to help you learn, give you new experience,
and treating your own neighborhood is a great
way to do that.
Tim Ferriss: So I'm giving some more — I
could keep going 'cause there's so many good
ones.
But I'll give an example of highly tactical
and specific, all right.
"To signal an emergency, use the rule of three:
Three shouts, three horn blasts, or three
whistles."
And then you have the more, I would say, still
practical, but conceptual.
"When you're stuck, explain your problem to
others.
Often simply laying out a problem will present
a solution.
Make 'explaining the problem' part of your
troubleshooting process."
And I —
Kevin Kelly: I wish I knew that so much earlier.
Tim Ferriss: I would not have been able to
write The 4-Hour Workweek had I not taken
this advice.
I was totally stuck on an entire section.
I was roadblocked, couldn't make any progress.
I was really starting to panic and a writer
friend of mine said, "Just have someone interview
you about why you're having trouble and record
it."
And I did that, I had somebody who was a ghost
writer, I've never used a ghost writer, but
she knew how to ask questions.
Recorded the conversation, didn't even need
the recording because it helped me walk right
through it.
And by the end, I knew what the solution was.
Problem solved.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Well, I have an assistant and when I get stuck,
I'll start to explain to her my thing.
And then by the end it's like, "Wait a minute,
I get it."
I was like, "I didn't need you.
But actually I did need you just to walk you
through it."
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
What would you hope — I'm going to ask you
the same question I asked about — is it
The Silver Cord or —
Kevin Kelly: The Silver Cord.
Tim Ferriss: It is.
I just wanted to make sure I was adding the
article or not.
So The Silver Cord, what would you hope this
to do?
What would be success for you?
Or is it already successful?
You're like, "Eh, I've done it."
Kevin Kelly: Generally my books have an audience
of one.
I did this big Asia book.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Kelly: 30 pounds, three volumes —
Tim Ferriss: Spectacularly, beautiful, gorgeous,
gorgeous, gorgeous book.
Kevin Kelly: — 9,000 images.
There was not one of —
Tim Ferriss: You took every image.
Kevin Kelly: I took every image.
Tim Ferriss: Wrote every caption.
Kevin Kelly: I did all the layout.
There's a thousand pages, each one has a different
design.
I did the whole thing.
And there's nobody who enjoys that book more
than me, just going through it.
Of course, I was there, but I made up one
prototype book, like this book here is a prototype,
and all I wanted was one book.
If there was no other books made, I would've
been happy.
But since I was making one, it is so easy
to make others.
And so it's like, "If I can share it with
you," send it to my friends, that makes me
even happier.
So the success for that was having the book.
This one is not so much for me.
It is if other people also can gain and find
ways to repeat these things and improve their
lives, that is success for me.
So I would hope that a young person like me
would hear some of this advice and be able
to encapsulate it and repeat it to themselves
and make their lives better.
That would be a success for me.
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to take a slight detour
because that is my wont.
I'm going to take a slight detour because
this is on my mind.
Do you still recommend sabbaticals?
Kevin Kelly: Oh, gosh.
Tim Ferriss: And how would you suggest, maybe
for people who have not heard our prior conversations,
think about sabbaticals?
The value of how to actually take a sabbatical.
What does that mean?
Kevin Kelly: Right, right.
No, I'm a huge fan of sabbaticals and I think
I had some advice in the book.
I put it that I think we over overemphasize
our productivity and efficiency, but the most
powerful thing you can do for productivity
is to — the best thing for your work ethic
is to have a rest ethic.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Actually, that's one I've started.
Kevin Kelly: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Something along the lines of
"The key to a great right work ethic is having
a great rest ethic."
Kevin Kelly: So this idea of, I think goofing
off, wasting time, sabbaticals, Sabbaths,
taking a Sabbath, are all essential to the
creative life.
They're absolutely, it's almost like sleep.
You just have to do it.
And it does it by rejuvenating you and shifting
your perspective by releasing you from — I
mean, there's just so many things that it
works on.
And most, I think for me, in my own experience,
the best things that I've done came after
taking — shifting.
It's the clutch.
When you're shifting, you want to put the
clutch in, otherwise you just kind of grind.
So I think it's really valuable.
And again, not just every seven years, which
is a technical sabbatical, but like Sabbaths,
vacations, but more importantly, time off
and goofing off.
And I think I find that the young people,
believe it or not, the ones that I am associated
with, don't goof off enough.
They go right from college and their first
job and it's like, no.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Kelly: Go.
There were people that Wired, they came right
from college and after seven years they were
still there.
I was like, I sit down, like "Why are you
here?
You should not be here.
I mean, when was the last time you goofed
off or wasted time?"
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Kelly: So no, I'm a big believer.
Tim Ferriss: I can imagine the rest of management
must have loved that.
Kevin Kelly: I was the management.
Tim Ferriss: No, were you the only management?
Anyway, we don't have to belabor the point.
I'm just management like "Why — wait, why
did seven people quit last week?"
"Oh, they've been talking to that Kelly."
Kevin Kelly: So I think it's essential.
And so your question of, whoa — this is
why I love you.
It's like, give me some practical stuff about
how to take a sabbatical.
Tim Ferriss: Or just what might it look like?
For someone who — I mean, let's personalize
it.
Like for me —
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — what might a sabbatical look
like?
What would you consider the minimal viable
duration and what would make it a sabbatical,
versus me just being in a foreign locale,
thinking about the usual stuff?
Kevin Kelly: So my wife's, both of her companies
she'd been at, she was at Genentech for 30
years, and she's at 23andMe now.
Well, Genentech had a sabbatical program,
an official one, and it was six weeks every
six years, which is basically a European vacation.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Kevin Kelly: An annual vacation.
So I think six weeks is probably, to me, the
minimum for a sabbatical.
But man, it could be very effective in six
weeks.
For me, I've done things like doing art is
something I like.
In the old days, you used to have — professors
would get sabbaticals and they would do their
own project that they were working on, or
go to a school somewhere or have a visiting
appointment.
Travel is a very, very common one.
For you, I think your effort right now to
work in animation and stuff — what's the
word I want?
Tim Ferriss: I could shadow.
Kevin Kelly: So I guess the general pattern
is you want something that's different in
the structure and rhythm from what you normally
do.
And so our temptation, those of us who like
to make things, is to make something different.
But that's not really a sabbatical.
We're kind of in the same rhythm.
We're learning.
And so it's sort of like you want to go in
a different direction.
And I did a sabbatical once where I just read
books and it was like literally, it's all
I'm going to do.
I'm going to get up in the morning and I'm
going to read books and I'm not going to do
anything else.
And that was really different from my normal
behavior, but incredibly powerful.
And by the end, I went to travel 'cause I
had to, it was like I blew my gaskets, I had
to go.
But that sabbatical of only reading books
and reading books all day long.
And I could read almost like about an average
of a book and a half, about a book a day.
'Cause some books are really short and some
are really long.
But I mean the synapse associations that you
get from reading a book after book after book,
you begin to think that they're all talking
to each other, the authors.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Kelly: I mean they're talking about
the same thing, they must have known about
each other.
It's impossible, but you have this sense of
this all knitting together.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Saturation.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
So I think the recipe is to have a different
rhythm and a different mode than you normally
have.
So I don't know, for you that might be something
like —
Tim Ferriss: I'm also used to making, making,
making.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: It could be interesting for me
just to shadow somebody for a period of time.
Kevin Kelly: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Somebody who's really good in
the world of, say animation, using that example,
and just watch.
I'm not allowed, actually —
Kevin Kelly: There you go.
I like that.
Tim Ferriss: To make anything for a while.
I just have to watch.
That would actually be very challenging for
me.
Kevin Kelly: It would be.
That's right.
Yeah.
It's like you have to watch somebody.
But I do that every evening on YouTube.
And again, I could rant about YouTube forever
because I think it's way underrated for an
influencer society.
Tim Ferriss: I heard a story, I'm not going
to name names.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Actually I can name one name
but I don't want to mention all the names.
So mutual friend, Matt Mullenweg.
Kevin Kelly: Right.
Tim Ferriss: We were just spending time together
and he said you went on a walk with one of
his friends.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And the two of you just talked
about YouTube for two hours straight.
Kevin Kelly: Yes, I know.
Tim Ferriss: So why don't you expand a little
bit?
All right, so what do you do on YouTube?
Kevin Kelly: I watch, I watch people.
No, no, no.
I'm sorry.
Tim Ferriss: "It's this thing called YouTube.
It has videos, Tim."
Yes.
Kevin Kelly: No, I watch people work.
Tim Ferriss: You watch people work?
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
I watch people making things.
Tim Ferriss: Like what?
Kevin Kelly: Like people restoring cars, people
making boats, people making clay things, just
watching people make things.
Tim Ferriss: Huh.
Kevin Kelly: And because I'm a maker and because
I learned so much by watching people work.
Much more than you ever learn in a book.
Tim Ferriss: And are these just full capture
videos or are they giving commentary as they
go?
Or are they just a kind of a peek over the
shoulder as they do their thing?
Kevin Kelly: All the above.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Kevin Kelly: All of the above.
Sometimes they're time lapses, them just in
the shop.
Sometimes they're giving lessons, sometimes
they're showing a technique, sometimes they're
walking through it.
Some record their mistakes, some don't.
I mean, I subscribe to so many that it's hard
to generalize.
But the point is that why I think it's underappreciated,
is that it's an accelerant on the learning,
the process of people discovering something,
putting it up, other people, other makers
watching it, seeing, "Oh, that's a good idea."
Tim Ferriss: It's like your visual —
Kevin Kelly: Modifying it —
Tim Ferriss: — your visual discord.
Kevin Kelly: Modifying it, putting their version
up, and then two days later someone else has
improved it.
And brain surgeons are using this right now
where a brain surgeon will have an operation,
they'll be filming their operation, they have
a little bit of a technique improvement that
they'll watch.
Other brain surgeons are watching brain surgeons
—
Tim Ferriss: On YouTube?
Kevin Kelly: On YouTube.
And within days they'll have an improvement.
And it's going this fast, unlike years and
years of waiting until a paper being published
in a paper.
It's like, how can you do that?
So it's this incredible accelerant and the
problem — not the problem, but the thing
about YouTube is it's all invisible.
It's not like a bookstore where you see what's
there.
You have no idea —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Kelly: — that this is happening.
And it's tremendous.
Tim Ferriss: It's like being in the libraries
of Alexandria with a blindfold on.
Kevin Kelly: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: And you're only allowed to take
it off once you grab something off the shelf.
Kevin Kelly: You have a little tiny peephole.
Oh, there's some books there about astronomy.
But no, there's this huge world.
So for me — but anyway, I like your idea
of watching people execute at work and not
having to produce something.
That would be a tremendous sabbatical, or
true sabbatical.
Tim Ferriss: It would also be such a shift
for maybe because so much of what I do is
virtual or on a screen that doing it say via
YouTube would not be much of a behavioral
shift.
And doing it in person, I also travel and
move around so much.
Being in, say, a fixed location for a period
of time —
Kevin Kelly: Right, right.
Tim Ferriss: — would be a very novel experience.
Kevin Kelly: Exactly.
Right.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Kelly: So I was thinking of the productivity.
There's one little bit of advice.
Actually, I was telling us to David Allen
of all people, who was the Getting Things
Done guy.
Tim Ferriss: Of course.
Kevin Kelly: There is a tendency — what's
the word?
The normal approach to organizing your life,
is that you want to be productive.
So you want to get through the things that
you need done the most productive way in the
least time as possible.
But I find it's better to shift over to say,
what are the kinds of things I want to do
that I want to spend as much time as possible
doing?
That to me is the focus, is to shift from
minimizing the amount of time on things, but
to maximize the amount of time to do things
that you don't ever want to stop.
Tim Ferriss: Where you want to maximize the
time.
Kevin Kelly: Right.
Tim Ferriss: That was one, I'm not going to
go through all the pages to find it, but that
was actually one I had my thumb on, literally,
that I was going to bring up because that
is a piece of advice in the book.
I have to ask because I've never been able
to figure it out, probably because I haven't
asked you specifically.
Why are you so — you're like the — David
Hasselhoff is to Germany, what you are to
China, you're huge in China.
What is the reason for that, do you think?
Kevin Kelly: It was an accident.
It was an accident.
So I wrote a book, Out of Control, in the
early '90s, that was ignored in the US.
It was way too early.
It was just too early.
It was talking about decentralized systems,
had a whole chapter on crypto in 1994, that
actually I gave to Steven Levy and assigned
him to follow up.
And he later wrote the book on the crypto
stuff.
Crypto not being the money, but mine was about
digital money.
And so it was just too early.
But it was translated into Chinese at the
beginning of the aughts, I don't know, 2006,
maybe five, I don't remember exactly.
And it was actually crowdsourced translated,
which was even more interesting.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, because there was so much
demand by the Chinese?
Kevin Kelly: No.
It was just some fans in China.
Basically it was —
Tim Ferriss: That's a task.
Kevin Kelly: It was crowdsourced.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I get it, but crowd — it's
still a task.
Kevin Kelly: So there was one guy, and I owe
it all to one guy, who was a real true fan
and he organized the crowdsourcing translation
of it.
And it came out at the right moment that Jack
Ma and Pony Ma were beginning to build their
— do their internet things.
And it was hugely influential on them.
And they talk about the book.
So everybody else, every entrepreneur in China
has to read the book because Jack Ma recommended
it.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
The Steve Jobs of China —
Kevin Kelly: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: — is talking about it.
Kevin Kelly: And that's primarily why it kind
of disseminated from that.
And then all my other things were translated
and I became the prophet of the internet or
something because I was talking about these
things before there was the things.
Tim Ferriss: Kind of what prophets do.
Kevin Kelly: And so in China there is a little
bit of more of a herd mentality where people
read it because other people have been reading
it and need to read it.
Tim Ferriss: Happens here too.
Kevin Kelly: But even to a larger —
Tim Ferriss: To a greater extent.
Kevin Kelly: And so most of my fans are actually
in China.
And I still was going there on a regular basis
giving talks about the future of X and Y.
And the major difference there was that they
were actively listening and then executing
and doing this stuff rather than — I mean,
they were so eager to build and to get ahead,
they would say, we're talking about whatever
it is, blockchain, whatever, "Okay, we're
going to start doing blockchain."
It was like they were absorbing it and actually
acting upon it rather than just kind of, "Oh,
that's a nice idea."
They were really looking for things to do.
Tim Ferriss: Very proactive.
Kevin Kelly: So it had a huge influence in
that way.
Tim Ferriss: So you said you're known as KK?
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Do they write it in the English
"KK," or is there — I'm sure they have a
Chinese name for you, but —
Kevin Kelly: They say it — there isn't characters.
Tim Ferriss: It's just the letter K, letter
K.
Kevin Kelly: They can read the letters.
Tim Ferriss: No, I'm sure they can.
Kevin Kelly: No, no, but I mean, it's just
KK.
I have a Chinese name.
Tim Ferriss: What is your Chinese name?
Kevin Kelly: Kǎiwén Kǎilì.
Tim Ferriss: That is a great name.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah.
Kevin Kelly: But —
Tim Ferriss: You could slightly change that
and sell yourself as a K-pop star in the US.
It's all the rage, you can do really well.
[foreign language].
Cool older brother.
Kevin Kelly: Yeah, right.
Tim Ferriss: That's you, man.
That's how I think about you.
Well, is there any other advice you'd like
to give or anything else you would like to
say about Excellent Advice for Living: Wisdom
I Wish I'd Known Earlier?
Or any other thoughts you would like to share?
Any closing comments?
Requests of my audience?
Kevin Kelly: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Formal complaints you'd like
to lodge?
Anything at all?
Kevin Kelly: Let's see.
No, I think there is one little piece of advice
at the very end, which maybe sums up the assignment,
which is kind of your goal in life is to be
able to say, on the day before you die, that
you have fully become yourself.
So I really want to emphasize this idea of
fully becoming yourself and the difficulty
and the challenge that is to discover what
that is, but how powerful that is.
And that's true whether you're starting a
company, or becoming an artist, or a teacher,
whatever it is.
And the reason why I'm very pro on technology
is that I think it enables us, helps us, generally,
to become more of ourselves.
That we all have mixtures of talents in us
that actually need external tools to help
us express things.
And so I am interested in increasing that
pool of possible tools in the world so that
all of us would have some chance to really
expressing our genius and fully becoming ourselves.
And that includes having clean water and education
and access to transportation.
Those are all the fundamental tools in addition
to the kind of high tech stuff.
But I really do believe that all of us have
a unique genius.
I mean, every evidence I've seen in the world,
and people around the world suggest that that's
true.
And so if I can at all unleash people to attempt
to fulfill their best self, to be more of
their selves, to be fully them, then that
would be a success for me.
Tim Ferriss: Kevin, it's so nice to spend
time with you.
So much fun.
Always is.
Kevin Kelly: It always is, Tim.
You make me happy.
I just love your sincerity.
Thank you.
Tim Ferriss: You too, man.
Thanks so much.
And I have read my little bootleg copy of
Excellent Advice for Living probably 20 times.
It really is something that you can refer
to again and again and again.
And each time you read it with a new pair
of eyes, because you're in a different state,
maybe a different place in your life, you
also glean different things.
So I really can't recommend this book enough.
It's so easy to read.
Excellent Advice for Living: Wisdom I Wish
I'd Known Earlier.
Go get it folks.
You will not be sorry.
You will thank me later.
And you can be found on Twitter, the tool
of the prophet, at "@kevin2kelly," and on
the website, certainly, kk.org, where people
can also find “1,000 True Fans,” which
everyone should read.
And for those listening, we will have links
to everything in the show notes as per usual
tim.blog/podcast.
Until next time, be just a little kinder than
is necessary to not just other people but
yourself and strive to become fully yourself.
And tools are part of that, advice is certainly
part of that, and maybe the combination is
part of that.
So till next time, thanks for tuning in.